good evening a conversation about Public
Safety that was the goal of a special
Town Hall head tonight in the Northwest
part of the valley we thank you for
joining us I'm Denise Valdez and I'm
Brian Loftis Clark County Sheriff Kevin
mcmahill one of many who attended to
acknowledge concerns and discuss
potential Solutions Sasha Loftus
children is live in the sky Canyon area
tonight Sasha has more
the growth of the Northwest Valley has
really ramped up in recent months with
development in neighborhoods you can see
like this but with more people comes
more crime the goal of tonight's event
discussing ways to keep everyone safe
she increased the population in this
area crime has increased concern over
criminal activity in the Northwest
Valley a lot of thefts a lot of jumping
over walls
walls a few of many who attended a
special Town Hall Thursday night what do
you see happening on the streets of
northwest Las Vegas to address any
issues at hand and discuss ways to solve
them and the number one issue we heard
from constituents was their concern
about Public Safety in the area city
councilwoman Nancy Bruni helped organize
the event what is being done which
touched on topics like overall crime
stats solution for the homeless
population Staffing and response and
overall efforts to connect with the
community the whole point is to build
some relationship which hopefully begins
to build trust Clark County Sheriff
Kevin mcmahill calls this one of the
many ways to tackle a rise in violence
across the valley the bottom line is
that we're experiencing a pretty
significant rise in homicide right now
as we sit here today we have 35 in the
city a lot of people who showed up tell
us they would like to see more action
taken to combat trouble in their
neighborhood it's not welcome that's for
sure while Mike and Veronica called this
a good first step to get the tools they
need to feel safe well I am glad that
we're here tonight
civilian employees were also there
tonight helping people form a
neighborhood watch programs and giving
them more tips to protect their homes
now event leaders tell me that they hope
this town hall is the first of many to
come reporting live tonight Sasha Loftus
8 News Now